do what you love and you'll never work a
day in your life yes have you thought
about what this quote means to you and
your last what decade and a half in LA
do what you love and you'll never have
to go to work or you'll never really
fully work it's mostly true it's mostly
surveilled 98% true but you know after
you do a hundred and twenty movies there
are some that there's some days when he
does work but for the most part if you
do what you love you won't have to go to
work why have you chosen acting as a
profession
I didn't choose acting I think like most
actors you won't find any actors that
have a sterling childhood to talk about
I think so you know mine I was the fat
kid the ugly kid the [ __ ] kid the smart
kid with you know I made straight A's I
couldn't throw a football I had bad acne
I knew all the answers in Sunday school
and I was really huge so the only the
only way that you can when you're in
that situation you can either fight back
or you can find a way to deflect and so
I just used entertainment for deflection
I think I've never met an actor who I
thought was any good who said well you
know my childhood was really great you
know so um I think just as a defense
mechanism
I chose acting I could also have been a
minister did you ever catch yourself
fighting back and at what point did you
turn it around and say let me use this
as something oh yes absolutely yeah I
remember vividly my acne was so horrible
that I would have a number of kid came
in and said can't you do something about
your face and you know only years and
years later did I think of the snappy
comeback no but I could do something
about yours you know but you never bad
asked when you need it I do remember but
shortly after that that I started doing
imitations of our teachers and
principals and I didn't care if I get
sent to the office as long as the kids
would stop picking on me and they
thought I was cool and so the first time
that they came up to me and didn't shove
me into the locker but instead said
do that imitation - mr. rice you do yeah
do that thing so I was their little
performing monkey but at least they
weren't hitting me so that's been the
whole thing is just the only reason I've
ever done this is to say please don't
hit me but if you entertain people
generally they won't hit you right so
it's good so in 2013 we met you at your
church I think was at First Presbyterian
in Holly
absolutely gorgeous and we've done
another interview with you prior to that
and when we turn off the cameras I think
you talked about how maybe you weren't
sure about continuing with acting is
this okay to talk about yeah it is okay
to talk okay because we can stop if you
want no no no no good yeah um so 2013 -
my math is right three years okay yeah
that's good
what are your thoughts now because we're
on a movie set by the way for the people
watching this in Altadena absolutely
gorgeous place it's that night it's
getting close to 11:30 p.m. and we've
just watched you perform it's a
fascinating scene I won't give too much
away I don't know if it's toward the end
but it's really cool I wish people could
see how neat it was up here and to watch
your performance we just kind of saw it
from the side and you're in a very NV
Abul position I was watching them put
this blood on you and it was just cool
but 2013 you said maybe this isn't for
you camera acting is funny because at
some point you have to become a product
or you're not able to succeed right so
in the beginning you - as much as you
can just because you love it and you
want to become established in this case
become established in LA but at some
point if you're going to have any value
to these productions the only reason
they're gonna hire you at above scale if
they're not hiring YouTube of scale
there's no point in it unless you're
rich the only way you're going to get
above scale is to become a product in a
commodity and that's the point at which
you have to find ways to reignite your
passion because once you become that
commodity
you lose a little bit of the love for
the craft and the passion for the craft
it's so easy to let it slip away and not
realize it and the worst thing is a
sense of entitlement when you're the
person that they bring in for two or
three days and then they put your name
above the title are very high up
you're the sizzle and they brought you
in to do the wrap around story or
whatever it is you're adding value to
the project it's so easy to to feel I'm
entitled to that and you're not you're
not you know so you forget how to be a
part of the team and I've been guilty of
that more than once so I have to work on
it
well you attended an event recently
where you got to be on the red carpet
which is something that so many actors
producers screenwriters all you know one
maybe that's not the end result for them
what can you talk about that experience
red carpets are a mind trip and you're
not prepared for them until you do them
now the first few that you do they're
great because for the first time in you
were LA career you're on the list and
you come up and they're oh yes of course
you know yes of course you're right do
it right this way where here's a gift
bag we're so glad that you're here
and then something really insidious
happens as you do more and more you
notice that there list you're not on and
you start to want to be on those lists
and so then you're no longer happy with
the list that you're on I'll wait till
they're gone but the more that you do
you begin to realize there's a hierarchy
and then something insidious happens
because you're on some list but you're
not on another list and you start to
resent the list that you're not on the
other thing that happens is
a disassociation with why you wanted to
do this in the first place because you
get a sense of importance and the sense
of importance comes from the little bit
of celebrity that you have and from
people treating you as if you are
something that you know you're not and
and I I think that this is one of the
root causes for addictive behaviors that
actors have it really plays with your
mind when people begin to treat you as
if you're something special
when and this actually happened to me
when you have just passed somebody
sleeping on a piece of cardboard on the
street twenty feet away from where
you're standing on a piece of industrial
carpet that's called the red carpet and
you're hearing people say one more bill
look this way
one more over here and you've completely
forgotten about that guy you never even
thought about him but if there was a
camera there you might use him as a prop
but you think you would never become
that person but I remember that specific
event when that happened and there's a
piece of video online of me and someone
else on the red carpet to remind me
forever that it happened and I also
remember the first time I went to a red
carpet and I was not on the list how
pissed I was and how entitled I felt and
I almost said the words don't you know
yeah
I don't know that red carpet culture is
a good thing at all for an actor I think
it really helps to break down your craft
but when you walked away from the event
where the gentleman was sleeping on the
cardboard what happened to you in the
following weeks shortly after that
particular red carpet I got a call from
a producer who said we really really
want to use her in this movie it was a
sequel but you've got to become more
famous than you are can you get more
famous we actually had that conversation
and then you you could hungry you get
hungry for more success more red carpets
more lists that you can be on to be
famous enough to be in that guy's movie
as opposed to the 55 other movies that
you've already got booked coming up you
want to be in the one that you don't
have how can I get more famous and then
I saw the video online of me looking
extremely uncomfortable doing this red
carpet dance well I know that there was
somebody sleeping on a piece of
cardboard 20 feet away and I just about
quit it just about made me quit because
I thought I can't do this anymore I'm
not a good celebrity what I wanted to do
with all of my tricks and all of my
magic online was to become a steady
working actor in LA and I did that I
became a very successful for me
working-class actor in Los Angeles but
what I did not count on was that there
is an additional element over which you
have no control and that is how famous
you are you can't control it but
everybody wants you to be more famous so
you can bring more money to their
project and if you get caught up in that
and thinking I need to be more than I am
you just become an ungrateful [ __ ]
and you start not to like yourself and
it's such a cliche it's such an actor's
cliche but people who come to this city
to work need to know that if they
achieve success they're gonna have to
decide how big a celebrity do I want to
be do I want to say the level I've
achieved is not enough I've got to be
big enough to be in that guys movie and
be on that series and are they able to
do it and for me no I I don't think I
want to be any bigger because I don't
want to be any more disassociated from
the world then I already feel so what
that little tiny bit of celebrity that
I've had that little bit of experience
what it did for me was it made me say if
you want to preserve any craft that you
have if you want to preserve any shred
of the reason that you became an actor
in the first place you've got to step
away and so I started doing theater more
and I started touring with a Ray
Bradbury piece that means something to
my heart and I started worried and not
so much about being important and I've
gone back east much more to be with my
family and my little beach house there
and it's been very good for my soul
and the more I think about it the more I
think that I don't really want to be a
movie star because I don't have what it
takes to stand on that red carpet and
not go to the guy who's sleeping on the
piece of cardboard and say you know what
man you should be on this red carpet
somebody takes some of this food that
costs so many thousands of dollars and
feed these people that are right here at
our feet but you see that's not a part
of celebrity that's not what we do in
this business that's not what we're
about we're about ourselves and my god
I'm self-absorbed enough as it is like I
can't do that anymore
so yeah so I'll never be a movie star
but I hope I can you know be a better
person then that person was well we've
had a few people reach out to us and say
that they watched your video on you know
sort of what it takes to be an actor
moving to LA and that that video was
part of the catalyst that got hit them
here you feel any kind of responsibility
any kind of joy in knowing that you
inspired people enough to leave their
family and friends and the safety of
where they grew up maybe maybe not and
come on you
I do feel a responsibility because of
the film courage videos because I have
heard from people and I actually met a
guy on the street I was in an event in
front of the Egyptian he said hey you're
that guy I came to LA after I watched
your video Wow and you you really did
but I told you not to come I said don't
do this and you did it you did it anyway
yes it's it's it's great and people were
right in the last advice and I'll say
look I don't know anything we only know
what works for us in this business we
don't really know nobody really knows
anything but yeah I'm happy to tell you
what little I do know right so then
going back to the red carpet event the
one where you weren't on the list where
you caught yourself in a moment where
you said
Mathers dead baby where you caught
yourself in a moment saying I don't like
that I'm not on this list and then in
the same moment I don't like myself for
not liking the fact that I'm on this
list
and some instance I mean don't you think
that that was almost needed because then
look something new came out of it and
that is you decided if I'm going to do
this it's going to be four roles that I
really feel a strong connection to not
something where they want to see the
monkey dance with more numbers yeah not
being on the list
and being turned away in front of people
that you know it's a good thing it's a
good thing because the way that you
react to it will show you how addicted
you were becoming to celebrity and when
that happened to me and I was supposed
to be on the list and there were people
there with me who were on the list and I
was really embarrassed and I was very
pissed and I'm ashamed to say that I
took it out on the person who had the
list who had nothing to do with it
with who was in the list or wasn't but
he really made me think it really made
me think because I was outside that
event looking in at all of the people
but I was in the same world you know the
birds sing on my side too but you forget
all of that when you're not on the list
when you think of your life as an actor
and the perfect life as being an actor I
should say what would that look like to
you the perfect life of an actor is to
be able to make a living at the craft
and nothing more than that to be able to
to do what we do and to sustain
ourselves and I don't know how it
happened but somehow acting God
associated with Fame and with celebrity
because if you say you're an actor then
people will say are you famous do I know
you
and their eyes glint could you be a
celebrity could they get close to a
celebrity
and when you say well you know I've done
a few and then they'll ask well what
have you done that I might know and if
you name a couple of your movies and
they don't know them then you see their
face fall OH
so I don't think it's a good thing to
think I'm going to come to Los Angeles
and I'm going to be a star I know that's
the dream it's hard enough to say I'm
going to come to Los Angeles and I'm
going to be a consistently working actor
that's a hell of a hard thing to do just
by itself yeah I think it's enough for
an actor to be a steady working actor
who gets to practice their craft in
theatre and in film and in television
all these different mediums that I've
been fortunate enough to work in if you
would come to LA at 18 how do you
envision your life your career being
different if I'd have come to LA when I
was 18 I would have been dead because I
would love this celebrity culture so
much that I would do anything anything
to be on the bigger list to be I can
feel it in my soul and I know I would
have sold my very soul to be that big a
celebrity to be a list yeah so I'm
really really glad that I didn't come
when I was 18 because no matter how
protected you think you are insulated
and grounded you think you are once you
stand up on the red carpet and once
people are stopping you on the street
and once people are saying yes of course
right this way here's your car you know
you come off the airplane and here's the
person with that stuff starts to build
up in you and you start to feel I
deserve that and so it's really really
good to have the kick in your pants or
not being on the list or thinking you're
going to get the pilot but you don't get
it because somebody more famous was
hired those are good things because they
rate they make you reach the crossroads
and the question is how famous do I want
to be and what will I sacrifice to get
there and for me I would have told you
before I came to LA I want to be very
famous
and I sacrifice anything but it's not
true it's not true it's not worth my
family fame is not worth my
relationships fame is not worth my
relationship with God fame is not worth
my heart the heart of an actor which has
to stay open I can't close it off so I'm
happy with my little tiny level of
celebrity I do my theater I do my films
like this one and you know if something
big ever happens that's great that's
great but I'm not seeking it I'm not
seeking it anymore
and if I never do another red carpet you
know it's okay oh yeah it's okay
so you went back home for a while after
the we'll call it the inciting incident
which was one of the two red carpet
things yeah and you contemplated giving
up acting yeah so how much time did you
kind of give yourself and then what
conclusion did you come up with I know
you said you really want to do theater
and you are yeah I think you're doing
something in Pasadena coming up what was
the process like I got into funk for
about four months after you know this
constant drone of you're a little bit
famous but you need to be more famous
and what can we do to get you more
famous and maybe we could you know I had
discussions with publicist well maybe we
could do a scandal all right you know
what can we do what can we do that's
going to go viral what can we do that's
going to go viral and yeah I got in a
bad funk for about three months and I
just went back east and walked on the
beach and you know didn't want to talk
to anybody and being around real people
is very good so if you're an LA actor
it's a really good thing I know you we
don't want to leave LA because you if
you leave you feel like you're missing
something you're not missing anything
take a break go back pet dogs be with
real people whose life doesn't revolve
around
being on the list and then you can get
some sense of what it is you want to do
and what the sense that I got after
taking that time was that I don't want
or need to be a star or a celebrity I
love what I do for a living and I love
it with a passion and I want to do it
and I'll do whatever publicity is
necessary to promote my projects I love
doing that publicity about things I care
about but I'm not going to say hey look
at me hey look at me
hey look at me and then be pissed
because that person's not looking to me
although all these other people I'm not
going to do that anymore I don't want to
be important anymore I have to wake up
every day and look in the mirror and say
it's okay if you're not important it's
okay if you're not a star it's okay if
people don't know who you are you're an
actor you're an actor
and that's enough